hi i'm eric arsenault and welcome to
your a approach daily vocal warm-up
i'm going to make this intro very quick
yes i am a professional vocal coach
slash vocal health consultant you've
seen my clients in televised vocal
competitions you've seen them in lead
roles on broadway and they're signed to
a plethora of major record labels and
now i want to share with you
some of the exact same techniques that i
use with my professional clients this
vocal warm up consists of four videos
and every single video will have
annotations on the side one of these
sides with intro coordination and
conditioning intro is just me telling
you the basic idea what we're working on
as well as the benefits of whatever the
exercise or technique is coordination is
about how to actually do it as well as
common pitfalls that many vocalists
encounter and ways to troubleshoot and
fix those issues and coordination is the
exercise itself that's when you're ready
to just get right to it especially after
a few days of practice you know what you
want to do that's just what you go to
when you just want to you know condition
your voice of course this video has the
additional welcome part to it and after
the day you never have to watch it again
my advice to you is that while it is
tempting to go right to the conditioning
part because i know that you might be
one of those who think i know how to do
it
watch at least for the first week watch
the coordination part every single day i
want to make this very clear it's not
enough to just go through the motions
your form and technique is everything
you would do much more good for your
voice by doing five minutes of quality
practice
than 30 minutes of rush hurried
hurry
um
half
way practice
you know what i mean so
pay attention to it form is everything
final thoughts for this welcome number
one do this every day it is daily yes
you want to go through the whole thing
every day so i want to make that clear
before i get any emails about it number
two this is good for any genre
any either sex it doesn't matter if you
sing rock music doesn't matter if you
sing gospel music vocal warm-ups and
vocal technique doesn't necessarily work
that way so it doesn't matter if you
guys i want to sing scream though i want
to sing blues still do the same thing
this is about making your voice healthy
reliable
and
that's pretty much that but uh and
making it more powerful so keep that in
mind so without further ado let's go on
to the actual lesson part of the video
oh and almost forgot
if you're interested in taking
one-on-one lessons with myself or one of
my associate coaches go to approach.com
for skype lessons or in-person lessons
or find out when i'll be in your city or
country with my vocal workshop tours
okay that's it we can go
[Music]
we're going to start with a body warm up
and i know that to some vocalist that
will seem strange because your vocal
cords are here your diaphragm's around
here but the rest of your body muscles
affect your vocal cords and your
diaphragm immensely we've all
experienced the tight throat we hate it
we've we know what it feels like to not
have this helping us we hate that we
know about tension in the shoulders
we've got to release up here and engage
down here and this video is going to
help you to do that
the body warm-up reduces strain it
improves fullness in the upper range
making belting a lot easier and it helps
to eliminate vocal fatigue
one more special note don't let the
simplicity of these exercises fool you
they are really easy to do they're
really easy to get
but
before you just brush them off as being
too simple or too silly try them once if
you're in the privacy of your home
nobody even has to know the worst case
scenario you'll waste 5-10 minutes of
your life and i'm sorry because you
don't get it back but the truth is it
works i promise you so do this stuff and
then sing a little song that you've sung
a billion times before and notice how
different it feels as well as how much
better it sounds it works don't be
fooled by the weirdness
welcome it welcome the weirdness it's
yours use it
we're gonna release some body tension
starting with the throat okay so what i
want you to do is yawn
just
i know it can be hard to yawn on command
but i want you to try you've been
yawning all your life you know how to do
this and you have the ability to trigger
it it's just an ability that you may not
have made use of because you may not
have had to but i want you to try it now
and as you yawn i want you to pay
attention to the inside of your throat
space you can keep yawning now as i talk
just yawn and pay attention
to that stretching feeling inside the
throat notice how your airway and your
throat space just completely releases
this is not the way i want you to sing
but just as a warm-up exercise it can
really release a lot of tension up here
and it can also help to release the
diaphragm a bit so i want you to again
just yawn
and allow the throat spacer just opened
up
you can do that a few more times if you
want if you want to pause the video you
can not we can just keep going the other
thing is
yes we want this to be relaxed but we
want this to engage and when i say this
i mean
the lower abdominal muscles well low
chest low abdominal muscles your sides
your back rib case muscles we want to
feel it down here we don't want this to
squeeze and tighten up but we do want
this to reflexively do it it's not
something i want you to force to happen
it's something i want you to allow to
happen so for that i want you to do a
gentle a gentle
gentle cough so we're gonna cough gently
as if we're clearing our throats like
and i want you to be aware of what
happens to this muscular region you
should feel some little contractions
super gentle now
not so gentle with where you can't feel
it but gently enough again
you feel it we're just reminding your
body
this is what i want and so what i want
you to do
now that we're moving on to some light
gentle lip rolls i want you to focus on
letting the throat space stay relaxed
and allowing the body to work
so throat is relaxed and the body gets
to
work a little bit we don't need this if
you relax the shoulders if you relax the
neck this will join in so let's start
let's make some sound with it so what
we're going to do is a lip roll in case
you're not familiar instead of
ah
we do
we're not actually going to even do any
skills right now we're just going to
just a simple little lip roll take a
breath
let it come out
liberal tribe just
just where it's comfortable no
particular note you don't have to match
my note just comfortable within your
speaking voice range
good now we're gonna work on teaching
our bodies to make the sound without
engaging the neck so you're going to
feel stupid in case you're new to these
videos let me just say a lot of the
stuff we're going to do is stupid at
least this house as far as how it makes
you look but it works and when we're
done you're going to be like oh it's
amazing and so just just be stupid with
me for now you'll reap the benefits i
promise so i want you to shake your head
from side to side like you're saying no
i tell my clients to think like in a
shampoo commercial like you've got
botanicals and stuff in your hair and
your hair is just bouncy it's that
gentle shake
it's not stiff but it's gentle and i
want you to lip roll with this so i want
a comfortable
and see if you feel
these muscles jumping in just a little
bit it'll be more subtle than the cough
but you might feel gentle contractions
around the abdomen the sides and the
back i don't want you to force it that
you allow it to happen
good now let's play with the range a
little bit we're gonna go from head
voice down to chest voice so
from this voice down into this voice so
instead of
ah
we're gonna go
try that
it's a really gentle way to wake up your
range but i want you to add the head
turn thing
you know it's like the patches head rub
your stomach thing but
distract those neck muscles
and one more time
okay good you'll also get used to me
randomly singing stuff
um it happens and it's contagious anyway
let's move on so you could do that
longer if you want again if it feels
good then you could do more it feels
good
well i get sued for using that little
bit of that tony tony tony song i hope
not um anyway so the next thing we're
gonna go to is going from chest voice to
head voice so going from the bottom
points up into the top and this is
normally where the stress and the
pressure comes where people want to
start to squeeze so i got a little cure
for that we're going to hunch our
shoulders really high i know it looks
crazy and then you're just going to let
them plop
and this is going to temporarily
disengage those muscles these muscles
that want to try to stop you when you're
going up because everything is connected
and if you start to tense here it's
going to cause a chain reaction of
tension that's just going to stop
everything so we're going to lift lift
and then
so just from bottom to the top from
chest voice up into head voice it's like
going uh
but we're doing it with a lip roll
just try that with me while i'm talking
so
shoulders up
and you should feel like this is nothing
your voice moves your upper body does
not so when you lift up tighten up you
know really get tight and then just
release completely
just let them plop so i'm not doing this
i'm not making them come down no i'm
tight and tight and tightening and then
i just
let go i feel that plop don't do this
too much i don't want you to dislocate
your shoulders but just listen one more
time reach reach
it's that simple that simple make sure
nobody's in front of you because if
stuff gets on it's embarrassing you get
that okay so let's try that again lift
lift lift
good last one
hip sockets
your pelvic floor has more to do with
your singing than a lot of singers are
aware of than a lot of voice teachers
give credit for we tend to think of the
diaphragm as being like a stomach thing
um and the muscles of your abdomen do
help control the diaphragm the muscles
of your torso help with the diaphragm a
lot and help to stabilize it and control
it for singing um
and the pelvic floor is a part of that
torso muscle family that helps your
diaphragm to do what it has to do so if
we're tight in the hip sockets or in the
knees it again causes the chain reaction
of tightness so a simple solution is
we're just gonna do a slight bend
so the same we did the shoulder drop and
then going up we're gonna
going to kneel down so
body goes down voice goes up
almost like being in a ballet class only
i might not be that graceful so let's do
it again
again starting from down and working the
way on up that's all we're doing all
right even if your sounds weak even if
your voice sounds like starting down
here and then
it goes into like a little high voice
that's where you can attach if it goes
into a detached falsetto that's okay
just keep practicing it make sure you
don't squeeze this all right so again
all right now we're going to go from
head voice to chest voice
so we're going to start up here and then
work our way down here but we're still
going to bend down why because i don't
want you to think of reaching up for
high notes because it's a surefire way
to clinch muscles when we brace
ourselves for handles when we tighten up
in anticipation then we just
we tighten up that's exactly what we do
i said it wrong we tighten up in
anticipation i don't want you doing that
i want you to think of releasing let
yourself sink to the floor for the high
notes
let your voice go down with your body
down into chest voice and again
it doesn't have to be that strong
that's fine but with a lip roll
why do i like adding lip rolls engages
the diaphragm in a wonderful way and
balances the pressure between the
diaphragm the vocal cords it really
teaches them to work together
harmoniously very easily
any of these exercises that we did
feel free to do longer if you go through
this video again
just continue to do the particular
exercise or release maneuver while i'm
talking it's that simple if you want to
spend longer on any of these feel free
they're very gentle very easy to do
um they teach your body very
foundational things don't
overlook the power of a yawn
don't let the simplicity fool you a yawn
is powerful a gentle cough to be aware
of these muscles is powerful lip rolling
and doing these weird movements powerful
sing a song that you always sing like
when i'm when you're done with this
video sing a song you always sing
something that you're familiar with
something that you know how you sound
and you know how it normally feels and
watch how different
it sounds and feels just after doing
this you might be surprised and after
you do that then i'll see you in the
next video